hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
and in this video I'm going to address a
question I get quite often and it's uh a
question that I think a lot of traders
that are new to orderflow have and the
question is you know what's the uh you
know sort of the best setup that I
should be looking for in the orderflow
okay so before I jump in you know if you
enjoy these videos be sure to subscribe
to the channel and hit the notification
Bell so whenever I post a new video you
you'll be notified of it all right so
let's uh jump into it so you know
orderflow is information basically right
it's it's how the trading is being done
um how it's transacting on the bid how
it's transacting on the offer and from
that there's a lot of information that
Traders can get you know there's Delta
um there's you know various Delta
numbers there's Max Delta Min Delta you
know cumulative Delta there's imbalances
in the bar buying imbalances selling
imbalances stacked imbalances multiple
imbalances points of control um you've
even got different types of points of
control um which which I won't get into
but basically you know there's a lot of
information and Traders tend to get uh
overwhelmed especially when they're new
to um looking at order flow and you know
so again you know to sort of circle back
to the original question or point of
this video is you know what's the one
thing you know if that's most important
in the order flow
well I don't want to say there's one
thing more important than the other
because you know all the information is
important and some times it's more
important that than uh other times but
if there was one thing that you know I
would focus on in the order flow sort of
as if I was beginning Trader with
orderflow is you know looking at the
footprint looking for those thin volume
areas you know there's a lot of people
talking about you know the heavy volume
you know which is okay but for me you
know if if I was a beginning orderflow
Trader I would look for those areas of
thin volume and and why is because you
when I have thin volume appearing in the
market it's often a sign of momentum
taking place in the market the market is
moving quickly okay so it's means it's
getting through uh you know various
levels of liquidity pretty quick and not
only that there is very small counter
trade right there's there's less trade
against it in the two-way auction and
you know if you're looking at the
footprint okay let me just get the
crosshairs going here
uh change that to Black here we go let's
make it a little stronger so if you're
looking at the footprint okay you know
you're going to see volume that was
traded on the bid volume traded on the
offer right in the two-way auction and
you know pretty much depending on the
market that you're trading now this is
e- minis this is a simple one minute
chart you know there there's going to be
decent volume traded on the bid and the
offer in the 2A auction now there's
going to be areas where there's heavier
volum volumes like you see most of these
bars have volumes basically between
about 25 and you know 80 okay then
there's going to be some price levels
that go into the hundreds some that go
even in you know the 200s and 300s and
you know sometimes even you know in the
thousands depending on the time of day
okay but what does that mean well
nothing it just means that there's
trading going on so what I would look
for right is the lack of volume one
against 27 in the 2way auction 13
against three in the 2-a auction um you
know these areas where there is just
very thin trade in the bid and offer
right when the market was bid and
offered at those price levels you know
maybe there was there was very little
volume there was no volume here when it
was uh trading seven seven and a quarter
traded 13 on the bid zero on the offer
at 7 and a quarter to me that's
important information it's information
that potentially I could trade from just
as over here when we come back up I can
see one traded on the bid now and 27
traded on the offer at 7 and
A4 okay and so you know I just I'd look
for these areas of thin volume in a bar
and the market how it's reacting know if
the market is moving through those
levels uh pretty easy because again thin
volume is a sign that the market is
looking for liquidity it's looking for
areas that it can transact more volume
at and you know I call these thin
prints um because it's in the bar and
it's just thin volume it's thin printing
of volume in the bar and we actually
have a tool on the orderflows trader
that's called thin prints specifically
so that you can highlight those areas in
the bar that have the thin volume so you
just open up the order flow
Trader okay and you click enable thin
prints
now the next step is to determine what
you consider a thin
print zero contracts meaning no
contracts traded either on the bid or
the offer in the 2A auction or you know
a volume one
contract maybe you know traded either on
the bid or the offer in the two auction
at that when the market was there or you
know two or three it's up to you um a
good starting point is one okay and you
just click apply now we'll draw it out
until
tested
okay the Zone F so where that area in
the bar where there's the thin print you
know the the lack of volume in the 2A
auction it's going to be drawn out so
that you can see you know right away
very easily you know in the bar here
here here here right there's one here
you know there's some selling ones here
bullish ones coming in here
now seeing them is one thing trading
them
sort of the next step right because you
know they are going to appear in bars
because you know that's just how bars
move bars tend to be um they can move
pretty uh quickly depending on the
momentum right and especially in the e-
minis you know the market can move uh
very fast now if you were say trading I
don't know um you know mnq NQ or or ym
you know I would treat it the same way
you know just as if I was trading Euro
currencies for me
me it's a go with trade because I know
the momentum is is going in a certain
direction right you can go with it right
today this is uh the 17th St Patrick's
Day right off the cash open you can see
the momentum very strong right after the
cash open you can see the zero
prints and a one print right in here
that's your thin print zero and one
right in the market just kept going in
that direction it had that momentum that
very strong directional trading right
from the open
right obviously jumped up from 95 all
the way up into the 20s all right so
that was a nice beautiful move hit our
swing high right after the uh Cash open
and then we sold off doesn't look like
much but it's uh it's a 10-point move
over three bars here and you start
seeing a couple more selling ones here
buying one in here um but wait for the
confirmation wait for the bar to close
and now again you know depending on the
type of bar that you're trading right
again this is a one minute chart you
know
if 45 seconds pass and we're trading
down here chances are we're going to
close there but if I see a thin print
come in in the first 15 seconds you know
you still got to wait for it to confirm
wait for the bar to close okay and you
can see these are areas where the market
will often come back
to right and sort of fill because the
thin print which is very small volume in
the two-way auction is poor order flow
and if you got the poor order flow
you're going to look for the market to
correct it right which it does come down
here and fill it's like a gap in a bar
right and if if you know anything about
Gap analysis you know that the market
will often come back and fill that Gap
now there is a there is a school of
thought with thin prints
that it will come back fill it and
then um you reverse off of that but
again you know it it it's a difficult
one to trade for a lot of Traders
because they don't want to sit through a
lot of you know basically losing trades
I mean if if you were to trade for a
pullback to here's your thin print right
here of
zero trades right to that level trades
two contracts and then rallies up okay
then you have a thin print here from
earlier it came right down to this level
you had one here came right to the tick
you have this one just blew through
another one blew through one that it
rallied off of right so can you take you
know the the word blows through here
where it blows through here where it
blows through here trying to trade it uh
literally to the tick you know but there
are there are traders that are willing
to sit through those losses because you
know if they can get elected on the
trade like
here right they're buying it right here
and the market rallies you know they
risk one or two ticks and then the
market rallies you know 30 ticks you
know they can sit through a lot of
losses unfortunately many Trad
uh aren't pre disposition that way right
they
they they they they want High winning
percentages right even though
the winning
percentages on something like this on a
trading a pullback you know you'll have
a very low winning percentage but your
risk to reward is can be quite
High you know so you see bearish ones
here bearish one here bearish one here
you know Market is coming off all right
now
sort of the where it gets a little bit
uh nuanced is the market that you're
trading so again this is e- minis this
is with a thin print set at zero or one
now if you were in a market like bonds
okay can you use 01 well of course you
can use zero or or one there's no nobody
telling you that you can't but this
Market trades a heck of a lot more
volume than say the e- minis
do so so if you're going to do that in
this market you're going to use the thin
prints okay let's just find it here thin
prints okay let's enable
it all right so default is set at three
so now it's showing me these thin
prints where it's coming in you know 58
against three 15 against 2 166 against
zero
okay zero against 598 0 against 248
um you know three right here you know a
zero right
here now again this is a a four range
chart you know with bonds I I prefer
four range but if you were using say a f
minute chart uh let's just pull up a FIV
minute
chart right you see the the way the
chart is constructed is a little bit
different but you still got your short
here
you're long
but how do you do you really want to
stay with a thin print of you know zero
or one two or three on on a market that
trades much stronger volume you don't
have to you could actually uh adjust the
volume threshold
from three where is it
here to a slightly higher number or even
I'll say slightly but you know you could
even make it say
25 if you wanted to cuz you know that at
this in this market it
trades a lot of volume so here you got
you got another bearish one here still
got the bullish one here you got a
bullish one coming in there um you know
the day before really
quick you
know is it bearish bearish bullish
bearish bullish bullish okay so
it depending on the market that you're
trading volume wise you know you could
adjust the volume right because at the
end of the day what you're looking for
what you want to focus in on is those
areas of thin trade in the two-way
auction okay
and what it represents is a market
that's moving fast and not only moving
fast but there's very little comp C
trade and if you got little counter
trade all right which is basically you
know trading on the bid or the offer so
if the bid trades very little and the
Market's moving up then you know the
market is moving pretty quick just as if
the market is moving down and there's
very little um trading on the offer that
means there's not there's no interest in
people lifting this
offer they're more interested in hitting
the bid just as over here 20 against 430
there's more Traders interested in
buying
than
selling okay and it's not just because
there's an imbalance you know there's a
there's an imbalance obviously 20
against 430 is an imbalance 96 against
469 is an imbalance but I know that in
this two-way auction at this price at
this time Traders were more focused on
getting on buying than selling okay and
that's information that you could use in
in your trading all right so that's uh
just sort of one of the tips that I
could give you on orderflow you know are
the things you want to be looking for in
the order flow on the footprint chart
specifically and if you're interested in
the footprints um you I did create a
course I'll put the link in the
description below called Footprints and
focus where I talk about how to get the
maximum out of the footprint chart so
thanks everyone I'll see you guys on the
next video